[Applause]
[Music]
nothing is nonsense you are not killing
yourself on my penis dr. Frankenstein
June and we talked I love green pills
but yellow works for me if it works for
you sit out when I call my dad he will
have me out of here in the nanosecond I
have placed your welfare completely in
the doctors hands whatever dr. Bernstein
says goes I'd like you join in a
discussion my senior men food these are
pictures of my ex-wife Mildred may she
rest in peace
when did she die I'm still waiting
writing the next great novel waiting for
your father - yep yeah I've always
wanted to meet dr. Bernstein well
hello huh you know I actually do but my
daughter Laura
you're selfish suicidal merde dual
addict without a job you love me oh
that's a sod nuthouse next time you jump
off a bridge you could prevent a
brilliant career death is forever it can
always turn
[Applause]
[Music]
we want you to grow up we'll see you
again see why they Joe tell me the first
thing that comes to your mind sex now
first you have to look at the inkblot
sex you know I'm crazy about you are
crazy